Hey look a lot of my teammates obvious
for them they out of the game so I'll
play when I'm with them you know you
play a lot of games against teammates
and sometimes you want to just play a
story mode where you could just put
yourself in position and like make
decisions as the player you got to add
some extra email swag to it yeah I
thought about this why no aggravating
when you don't hit them all same feeling
I gave on the hill when I missed the
ball same feeling I get on the game when
I miss it might be better life actually
yeah well to me that's gonna talk for a
football player to play baseball because
they are so big you know t-38 egative
yeah I want you to feel comfortable
all right ready try to be natural we're
here now remember you you're gonna do a
football Michael you're gonna keep tight
the way here same thing when you swing
this is a yeah Oh crikey a baby here we
go
all these culture boys our work is just
I gotta get that rhythm nah you're gonna
make some throughout the tour well you
are we gonna get behind the ball gotcha
right left and go okay go football more
like attack right now attack attack
attack here you gotta have like some
patience technique and always be in
attack mode
that's perfect right there video game
stuff real life was definitely a little
bit more challenging time work man it's
like great coaches nice yeah
[Music]